[Musique]
cette agression contre la nature se
perpétue le but chose la plus haute
montagne de baffes la télévision ya
planté son chapiteau et les immeubles
haut jaillit du sol
mais la banlieue champêtre s'accrochent
encore à quelques lambeaux de terre
ultime refuge du plaisir de vie
m
et
et puis voici une belle ville un des
derniers villages du grand paris en 1830
tout un peu plus joyeux de maraîchers et
de vignerons écueil est ici les
parisiens souffrent déjà du mal de la
ville les écoles un rire se sont éteints
mais entre les murs lézardés des maisons
des amoureux de la nature cultive encore
obstinément de charmant petit jardin
un modeste potager près d'une voie
ferrée à ménilmontant des employés des
chemins de fer perpétue se réconfortant
miracle
un coin de banlieue
non pas du tout la plaque rhin et danube
se fait d'abord une carrière de pierres
nommé carrière d'amérique puis un marché
aux chevaux
aujourd'hui c'est encore un refuge pour
ceux qui veulent se donner l'illusion de
fuir la grandville
c'est ici qu'est né au coeur de
belleville celle qui savait si bien
faire battre le coeur de parc des murs
gris
un escalier étroit
une vieille mansarde
et me voir à chez moi
vicky secondes
une table devient mois
ça fait drôle
emma
et que mon club et pardon malheureux
et quant aux mairies dont de maple
et régal
dieu
le long
dans l'ue
à une fillette à la vie qui a tout ce
qu'il faut et même
non
un autre sommet le bar et la colline de
chaillot au siècle passé pour niveau ni
respirer l'air des cimes sophie arnould
lafayette
madame d'epinay barras chante pas il va
refaire déclaré oxygène et puis voilà
qu'un jour de 1720 ab qui fut l'aumônier
de madame de maintenon y découvre 300 se
fait rugir
du coup pas s'y est lancé et devient la
station thermale à la mode
pas de l'étoile ce paisible le battage
et n'est pas un jardin ordinaire il
plane à quelque 50 mètres du sol et
abris sont ces massique 65 mille mètres
cubes d'eau c'est le château d'eau de la
rue lauriston qui offre à ses voisins le
privilège d'une permanente évasion de
verdure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quittons l'ancien village de passy
poursuivi d'auteuil il y a deux siècles
les paysans mais ici leur belle au chant
veaux vaches et cochons ont déserté le
16e arrondissement
et les canards plat paris ce n'est pas
si banal
en 1847 un célèbre administrateurs
blanche y installa sa clinique
il avait duré pensionnaire de qualité le
cher gérard de nerval le poète en effet
avait dû faire un séjour chez le médecin
à la suite d'une certaine promenade au
palais royal où il tenait en laisse
homards vivants
[Musique]
à
et
oh
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces maisons de campagne parisienne ces
jardins miniaturisés qui semble refléter
la nostalgie des années folles
on un créateur commun l'architecte
mallet stevens
[Musique]
m
et
non vous n'êtes pas au coeur de la
savane brésilienne
m
ce perroquet habite rue raynouard c'est
un parisien authentique tout comme cette
tortue d'ailleurs quant à l'exotisme
tropicale qui vous est offert il n'est
pas baigné par le fleuve d amazon mais
plus simplement par la scène
ce spectacle
celui que balzac avait sous les yeux
lorsqu'il habitait la maison voisine
combien de personnages de la comédie
humaine sont nés dans la contemplation
de s'étendre bis
non
dans un joli château qui s'appelle le
château de passy vivait jadis une belle
princesse la princesse de lamballe sa
promenade l'amener souvent dans ses
allées fleuries
tél il ne reste plus qu'un fantôme
gracieux et du parc du château quelques
morceaux de jardin qui suffisent à
dépayser le promeneur
[Musique]
oui
au milieu de son univers de béton
il arrive que le bâtisseur des temps
modernes un terreau parfois sa course
fatale et sème des arbres au milieu des
pierres
les immeubles de la rue des belles
feuilles tout près de la place
victor-hugo démontre qu'on peut édifier
une cité nouvelle tout en lui donnant
les moyens de respirer il s'élève sur
l'emplacement de l'hippodrome ou 10000
spectateurs s'entassaient aussi à te
dernier pour admirer la parade du plus
vaste cirque parisien
laissons le rythme de la ville reprendre
ses droits juste le temps de traverser
paris le lion de belfort
le faubourg saint-jacques
l'hôpital cochin
maintenant regardez bien ce bel hôtel au
milieu des jardins de province lui
arrive est la plus étonnante des
aventures il a déménagé
oui vous avez parfaitement entendu
l'hôtel de massa a changé de quartier en
1928 et ça devait encore rue la boétie à
deux pas des champs elysées
mais tel quel il gênait fort des
promoteurs immobiliers qui lâche terre
pour lui substituer un immeuble moderne
mais le ministre de l'instruction
publique de l'époque qui s'appelait
edouard herriot n'accepta pas cet
holocauste et puis à part pierre l'hôtel
de massa furent édifiés sur cet
emplacement où ses frondaisons abrite
désormais à société des gens de lettres
[Rires]
oui
ici ce sont des dominicains qu'il faut
vivre un beau jardin
rue des tanneries sous laquelle coule la
bière grâce à ce jardin les habitants du
quartier peuvent durant quelques
instants aux milliers les fumées de la
ville et respirait comme à la campagne
les moineaux même suspendu un jardin sur
le toit de nom
ce sont les mêmes rêves de verdure les
mêmes besoins de nature qui ont permis
qu'on crée un espace vert entre ciel et
terre au 26e étage d'une tour
la glacière
puisse ce salutaire exemple être suivi
par tous les bâtisseurs de notre cité
[Musique]
les défis il ya un siècle la cité
fleurie abrita des générations
d'artistes entre autres gauguin
modigliani rodin bourdelle mayol c'est
idiot de quiétude est fatalement
aiguiser l'appétit des spéculateurs mais
les indigènes veiller sur leur village
et la cité fleurie fut sauvée
[Musique]
notre promenade aujourd'hui s'achèvera
dans ce grand jardin qui abrite les
institutions de sourds muets
seul louis avant de partir pour la
croisade 20 fonderie si la commanderie
saint jacques diop à plus tard la
commanderie de vins d'abbayes
saint-magloire puis le séminaire des
prêtres de l'oratoire il parmi leurs
élèves les oratoriens avait un jeune
garçon fort distraits qui ne
s'intéressait qu'aux jardins
il est vrai qu'il se nommait jean de la
fontaine
de nos jours les élèves de l'institution
retrouve les pas du grand fabuliste et
au gré de leurs désirs faut pousser ici
des fleurs des fruits même des légumes
ainsi vous l'avez vu grâce à une poignée
d'aventuriers de la nature paris vous
réserve encore des joies scène et
champêtre si chacun prenait conscience
du rôle indispensable de la nature
dréville il ne serait pas toujours
nécessaire de prendre sa voiture pour
aller la chercher au loin
[Rires]
[Musique]